bonjour
tous et bien
num pour ce troisième
art et aujourd'hui nous allons
créative alors avec deux package en
particulier qui vont nous faciliter
grandement les choses qui sont le
package et ismérie qui va nous permettre
de faire des tableaux de grande qualité
et le package esquisses l'objectif c'est
pour cette cette séance alors certes on
n'a pas encore vu tous les outils de
manipulation de données
mais avec ces deux paquets jean sera
normalement armé pour faire des
premières analyses
et puis on ira plus en profondeur et
plus en finesse dans lors des prochaines
séances
alors je vous propose on va tout de
suite mettre les grands cran ça sera
beaucoup plus facile pour arriver à
suivre
et puis avant de démarrer on va déjà
abordé rapidement la notion de projet
dans leur studio
en effet on va commencer à faire des
analyses on va écrire des premiers
scripts et il devient du coup très
important de commencer à bien organisés
et nos différentes doter nos différents
fichiers
l'idée principale dont un studio c'est
que pour une analyse données ou sur un
projet donné on va ranger tous les
fichiers correspondants nos fichiers de
données noscript d'import no script de
nettoyage et recodification dans un même
répertoire va permettre de mieux
organiser ce que l'on fait sur sur son
pc mais en plus on va le voir avec les
studios on peut très facilement passer
d'un projet à l'autre alors l'idée c'est
qu'on va tout d'abord créé un nouveau
projet pour ce soir et je sais pas si
vous voyez mais en os de verre studio
haut à droite
là on me dit actuellement project note
puisque j'ai ouvert un studio sans me
mettre dans un projet et on va tout de
suite créé notre tout premier projet si
je clique ici j'ai une option qui
s'appelle new project qui
alors on peut écrire créer différents
types de projets vachement content
chaussée pour des gens plus avancée
inquiète id outils comme guide
rosen pour notre part on va simplement
créer un nouveau répertoire pour notre
projet alors vous avez également pas mal
d'options qui correspondent en fait à
des applications plus avancés ou la
création package nous on va faire un
projet vide
donc on retiendra seulement l'option new
project
je vais lui donner un nom alors mon
projet je vais appeler webinaire 03
puisque c'est notre séance du jour il
faut savoir que le nom que l'on donne à
notre projet sera le nom du répertoire
qui va être créée on va ensuite choisir
où est-ce qu'on le même donc je vais
tout simplement mettre ça dans mon
répertoire documents mais ça peut être
suivant comment vous est organisé dans
un répertoire recherche ou dans un
répertoire qu'elle compte votre pc et
donc du coup je vais cliquez sur quake
project alors à ce moment
ça va tout simplement créé un nouveau
répertoire seront donateurs et si je
viens ici quand vous affichez ça j'ai
maintenant dans documents un nouveau
répertoire qui s'appelle webinaire r0
droit et qui va contenir par défaut un
fichier poulet reproche donc le fichier
pour les reproches gens ça permet de
dire air studio que nous sommes dans un
projet erp et ont peu et ça stockera
éventuellement quelques personnalisation
qu'on va on pourra avoir par la suite
l'idée c'est que toutes les données et
tous les scripts qui vont être relatifs
à notre projet vont être mises dans ce
répertoire là et ça définit également ce
qu'on appelle le répertoire de travail
sous verre à qui et quand on travaille
qu'un projet directement et vous avez la
formation ici dans le répertoire du
projet l'intérêt c'est que si vous avez
plusieurs projets bon on peut passer
d'un projet à l'autre par exemple à
gérer votre projet web in her alors
c'est le sait le code du site web
associé au webinaire et quand je clique
ici je vais fermer le projet en cours et
ouvrir une nouvelle session avec ce
nouveau projet il se souvient des
derniers documents qu'on avait pu avoir
ouvert il va recharger et venteux -
environnement si on l'avait en mémoire
et il nous a également changé de très
peur de travail pour être dans le
répertoire du projet je vais revenir sur
mon projet d'aujourd'hui donc c'est le
projet webinaire 0,3 et donc
coup avec cette histoire de projets on
peut facilement passer d'un élément de
travail un autre alors pour ce soir on
va ce qu'on va faire on va déjà
télécharger des données qui vont nous
servir d'exemple on va importer ces
données là et puis on va commencer à
faire quelques analyse descriptive
alors pour les donner d'exemple
ce soir on s'est préparé sur le site
oui binaire dont vous avez un je vous
rappelle ici le site l'art marange point
youtu.be au slash webinaire qui est le
site associée aux différentes sessions
que nous avons et vous avez sur le site
un menu séance
s'ils jouent
aujourd'hui du 10 décembre 2020
vous vous y retrouverez la vidéo du
webinaire également des liens vers des
chapitres du site analyse air qui
viennent compléter ce qui sera vue je
vous ai également mis quelques
ressources de documentation en anglais
et puis nous avons également ici un
fichier de données qui s'appelle foire
aux poulains xlsx alors on va le
télécharger est ce que je vais faire je
vais l'enregistrer du coup dans mon
répertoire de travail donc document
webinaire est à 0 3 et puis parce que
j'ai envie de ranger un peu tout ça je
vais faire mes mains sous clé donné et
je vais enregistrer mon fichier excel
dans ce sous répertoires donné de mon
projet alors nous
non dans les studios vous voyez dans les
studios que l'onglet en bas à droite
si vous avez un sous l'onglet fall ce
qui vous permet de voir les fichiers
qu'il ya localement on voit le ce
répertoire donné que je viens de créer
si je vais dans mon sous répertoires
veux voir mon fichier de données toi au
point xlsx est donc un fichier au format
excel si j'ouvre le fichier
alors on
la s'ouvre et je vous présente
et excelle de données alors c'est un
fichier structuré avec des variables en
colonnes et des observations en ligne
c'était un fichier de données qui
correspond à un essai clinique
imaginaire mais ça ressemble à un essai
clinique où on a 200 patients atteints
d'un cancer et ses différents patients
ont reçu un médicament un médicament à
un médicament b on a également l'un de
ses patients
le grade du cancer et puis un état
d'avancement du consel et puis on a
également une variable indique si le
patient est décédé
et s'il a une réponse positive ou non
aux traitements
alors la question
on sait comment est-ce qu'on va importer
les données dans leur studio et pour ça
et puis après on va faire une petite
analyse donc on va créer un script qui
va à contenir toutes les informations
dont on a besoin pour rappel on va créer
un script en cliquant sur le petit
bouton plus en haut à gauche
je veux un nouveau script r et puis bah
première chose que je vais écrire dans
mon style je lui donnais un titre je
vous rappelle un groupe donné à des
commentaires avec le symbole kiev j'ai
donné un titre analyse descriptive du
fichier
3 je vais tout de suite sauvegarde
des fichiers alors je ne sais quoi faire
simplement la combinaison contrôle s
pour sauvegarder ou sinon je clique sur
le bouton sauvegarde comme c'est la
première fois les âmes proposé
d'enregistrer le fichier et je vais le
mettre dans je vais ranger du coup mon
script dans mon projet ce qui vient
d'avoir toutes les données ensemble et
donc du coup je vais l'appeler cette
analyse ce script il est point air
puisque c'est un script ce qui va
contenir du codever première chose que
l'on va faire et bien au tout début du
script en général on va charger en
mémoire les différents package dont on
va avoir besoin
tout au long de nos analyses et puis on
va venir compléter cette partie là alors
et récemment que nous allons travailler
plus spécifiquement dans notre cas avec
les différents package du tailles
diverses qui contiennent des paquets ce
qu'ils vont être manipulé nos données de
faire fondre de transformation et qui
contient notamment ggp lot 2 est un
package qui va nous permettre de faire
des graphiques
alors aujourd'hui on va juste avoir une
courte introduction à gg pelote 2 grâce
au package est ce qu'ils vous allez voir
ça va faire beaucoup de choses de
manière assez simple mais malgré trou
pour avoir la taille d'hiver sont des
mois on va le chargé et on peut utiliser
du coup la commande library pour rappel
library permet de charger un package et
si je charge le package taille diverse
génériques
alors pour rappel pour envoyer
facilement une commande de mon script à
ma console jeu le raccourci contrôle
entrée sinon je pourrais juste me mettre
sur la ligne en question cliquez sur
wayne quand on charge taille diverse en
fait ça va automatiquement chargés un
certain nombre de package qui sont ggp
lot 2 thibal either with up your des
taillères stringer fourcade pour une
présentation un peu rapide
ggp lot 2 nous l'aborderons tout à
l'heure il va nous permettre de faire
des graphiques et au mois de janvier
nous offrons des cessions a dédié à gg
peu d'eux parce qu'on fait on peut aller
assez loin avec ce package siebel est un
paquet ce qui fournit une gestion un
petit peu plus propre des tableaux de
données tide hier et du plat hier son de
pâques et ce pour manipuler nos données
et nous les aborderons mois de janvier
or caps et permet de manipuler des
facteurs screen guerre des filles des
vecteurs textuel nous les aborderons là
encore plus tôt au mois de janvier
rider on l'avait abordé rapidement la
dernière fois ça permet d'apporter des
fichiers textuelle et pio et plutôt
dédié à la programmation un peu plus
avancé donc première étape de notre
travail ce qu'on va faire c'est importé
notre fichier excel
donc je
mais un commentaire un port des données
et je vous rappelle la petite astuce et
si on fait suivre de 4-1 au moins
automatiquement ça va être interprétée
par les studios comme un titre de
section et donc sa part ici en dessous
et dans un plan en haut à droite qui
bascou le plan de notre document alors
ce que nous voulons faire c'est importer
un fichier excel qui elle forma l'un des
formats les plus simples et c'est
souvent un format dans lequel vous avez
aux différentes données vous pouvez vous
référer toujours aussi tana l'isère et
alapage et taillé sur l'import des
fichiers de données mais avec un studio
c'était assez facile puisqu'on a
directement un petit outil qui est
disponible en haut à droite avec une
pointe à 7
donc si je
qu'ici je vais choisir forum excellent
je vais
avec bronze chercher mon fichier qui est
de coude en donner trois points xls il
n'y a qu'une seule
il n'y a qu'une seule feuille excel
dedans donc c'est assez facile nos
données sont désorganisés en observation
et en cologne a pas de ligne a supprimé
on est vraiment dans le le cas le plus
simple à
je vais cliquez sur first flight games
pour dire que la première ligne contient
le nom des différentes variables
vous voyez ici comment les variables ou
être interprétées trt a été décrété a
été détectée comme étant une variable
type textuel h comme une variable job
c'est à dire d'une musique et je vais
juste décoché opendata viewer car je
n'ai pas besoin à la fin et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le code en effet en
donc ici vous avez un petit icône en
forme de blocs de papier je clique
dessus ce qui me permet de récupérer le
code j'annule ici et je vais aller
coller le code dans mon script ça me
permet
tout simplement de pouvoir récupérer en
fait ce qu au delà directement dans mon
script et donc du coup après de pouvoir
leur exécuté sans avoir besoin de passer
par le menu donc menu ici me sert
simplement à récupérer du code pour
faciliter cette production de code pour
faire l'import j'aurai besoin du paquet
sous vide excellent qui le package
taille d'hiver qui permet d'importer des
données excel est ce que je vais faire
je vais le déplacer au tout début
un pour avoir en fait un seul endroit
avec tout un les paquets dont j'aurai
besoin je vous le rappelle si je devais
fermer
je vis
d'exécuter et ça bien créer un objet
travail supposons je ferme
r
on me demande
niches dit oui je vais relancer
r tu diot le tour
m je ne ferai pas
ce que c'est moi le 30 mai
un écran géant
studio et ce qui se passe qui à chaque
fois que je ré ouvre un projet la
particularité c'est que ça relance une
session de r et donc tous les paquets ce
que j'ai charge en mémoire ne le sont
plus si j'essayais de relancer cette
commande la voyez j'obtiens une erreur
impossible de trouver la fonction web
excellent parce que je n'ai pas
recharger le package voie d' excellent
mais moi c'est pour ça que ce que je
vous conseille c'est de faire tout vous
appelle le package au tout début de
votre site comme ça au début session de
travail
c'est très facile de régler qtc
différentes commandes d'un coup alors
regling
à la flèche oui l'excellent dead royal
pointe à la 6 et donc regardons
maintenant ce que j'ai obtenu
donc vous voyez en haut à droite que
dans l'environnement j'ai un objectif
royal de 200 observation aigüe variable
si je clique sur la petite icône
je peux voir du coup dans le navigateur
à le contenu de mon fichier qui a été
correctement importés et donc du coup
j'ai maintenant un fichier de données
qui à disposition si je voulais
sauvegarder ses données là après
l'import on peut avoir recours dans ces
cas-là à une fonction nous n'avions pas
encore vu que la fonction ses vins ses
élèves
on va tout d'abord lui donner le nom de
l'objet ou une liste d'objets à
sauvegarder puis on va préciser un chat
avec file est donc là moi ce que je veux
c'est enregistré ça dans un fichier
devait aussi mettre dans le sous
répertoires données donc je vais écrire
données slash chao coin air data
donc on donne toujours ce qu'on appelle
un chemin relative c'est à dire un
chemin vers un fichier au départ de la
racine du projet est pour rappel la
racine du projet c'est le répertoire
webinaire 0,3 si j'avais écrit
uniquement royales air data sam
enregistrerait dans un fichier qui
s'ouvrait dans ce répertoire webinaire
0,3 si je tape données flash toyal pour
air data sa enregistrera un fichier 3
yal point air data dans le répertoire
donné si j'exécute cette commande là
vous verrez maintenant bas à droite que
dans son répertoire donné j'ai un
nouveau fichier qui s'appelle travers le
point air data et le format point air
data c'est le format de données propres
à r donc c'est un format qui pratique
pour sauvegarder des données r ça peut
être n'importe quel type d'objet des
tables donner des listes des valeurs des
vecteurs
mais c'est pas un format qui pratique
pour échanger avec d'autres utilisateurs
c'est à dire qu'entre utilisateurs de r
on peut échanger le fichier 3 yards pour
air data et mais si je devais changer
avec une scie d'atr d'un autre logiciel
s'exporterait au format excel ou au
format texte ou alors je vois dans les
questions ici une petite question
concernant ce qui s'est passé au moment
où l'on a chargé le tailles diverses
puisque au moment où on a chargé de
taille diverse 1 dans la console
on voit d'une part qu'il attachait les
huit paquet en question y pied une parle
de conflit qui nous dit 10 player filter
masque parce sitter et du plat hier
l'ags masque stats lag
alors ce que ça veut nous dire en fait
c'est que au moment où on a chargé dit
pierre duplaa hier à une fonction qui
s'appelle filter et filter est aussi une
fonction qui existe dans le paquet de
stats stats c'est un des package de base
des verts qui est toujours chargée en
mémoire est ce que nous dit en fait ce
message là c'est que et bien la version
du player va masquer la version de stats
alors il faut pas s'en sont inquiétées
en fait que propose des plats hier avec
flipper et l'accès des versions plus
avancées de ces deux fonctions que
celles qui sont de base dans le package
ou stats et donc donc vous n'utilisez
pas les fonctions filter et lacs de vous
en inquiéter pas et un peu plus tard on
reverra ses fonctions là est en fait un
usage
il n'y a pas de particularité c'est
juste que tu ailles diverses préfère
être précis et nous informe et voilà que
kylie a du coup un conflit de nom entre
différentes fonctions ça peut arriver
assez régulièrement un peu certes un
package de package et une même fonction
avec le même nom et dans certains cas ce
qui est compliqué c'est que ces deux
paquets de jeu ne connaissent pas l'un
l'autre et en fait les deux fonctions
dont quelque chose de complètement
différent
dans ces cas là il est toujours possible
d'appeler la fonction spécifiquement
d'un package avec cette écriture de
points deux points c'est à dire que si
je tape lag
ils veulent chercher une fonction lag en
émoi
là en l'occurrence il ira prendre
d'abord la fonction de dix playa parce
que déployèrent été chargé en dernier
puis la fonction de stats mais s'il
écrit at c'est à dire dont un package
deux points deux points lag ça ira
chercher la fonction lag du package
stats
si jamais j'écris dit là hier
deux points
un lag ça ira chercher la fonction lag
du package type là hier donc l'écriture
non d'un package deux points deux points
non une fonction permet d'utiliser une
version spécifique c'est-à-dire qui
comprend au point spécifiquement telle
fonction de tel package
cela a également un autre avantage c'est
qu'on peut également charge pointé sur
une fonction que l'on n'a pas chargé en
mémoire par exemple je pourrais me dire
mais le package ou d'excès l'islam
servir uniquement au moment de l'import
gens n'auraient plus besoin derrière
donc peut-être que j'ai pas besoin de
charger de tout le paquet dans mémoires
a autant s'économiser ceci est donc ce
que je pourrai décider de faire c'est
d'écrire toutes formes ses idées
elle 2.2.1 rydex m
est supprimé
je mens mémoire en effet lorsque l'on
indique le nom une fonction précédé du
nom du package
elle est en capacité d'aller chercher
cette fonction dans le package
correspondant même si on
chargé ce package en amont donc du coup
on peut aussi que cette écriture là pour
chercher une fonction d'un paquet sans
avoir à charger tout le package
alors on va
c'est déjà
faire un tout
deux statistiques descriptives et on va
commencer avec la statistique dit
univariée la statistique univariée
consiste à regarder une seule fonction à
la fois
alors
ce
pour rappel 1
une idée un petit peu juste un coup
d'oeil sur les données que l'on a dans
un fichier on peut avoir recours à deux
fonctions il ya d'une part la fonction
de lyme ce qui fournit par des placards
et comme on a chargé dès l'hiver c'est
la disposition dont clint sont de trois
ordres nous permet d'avoir une vue
consiste notre tableau de données on a
du coup puis variable avec des variables
textuelle et des variables à numérique
et puis on a aussi une fonction
intéressante et d'un package la bad
alors on va se charger label d' en
mémoire et si vous vous souvenez on a
une fonction qui s'appelle look fort
variable à disposition on va commencer
par la statistiques descriptives pour
une variable numérique
donc là on va s'intéresser à l'âge et
bien les fonctions de base pour le faire
usuellement quand on veut connaître d
informer pour résumer notre variable on
peut avoir recours à la fonction mines
donc si je fais mine de 3h je calcule la
moyenne
voyez là il y avait une valeur manquant
de récupère donc une valeur mon compte
et pour préciser que je veux calculer ma
moyenne sans les valeurs manquantes et
na poin rm égal tout on a aussi la
médiane les médias ne permet de séparer
bon
en deux groupes de même taille et donc
ça se calcule directement avec médiane
et donc on est une médiane de 47 ans on
peut aller un petit peu plus loin à
vouloir calculer des quand il encore une
fois on a une fonction qui à peu près la
même sens comment elle s'appelle quand
il par défaut sont calculées les comptes
il à 0 25 50 75 et 100 % c'est à dire le
minimum le maximum et des cartes il mais
on pourrait éventuellement être
intéressé par avoir plutôt les cats il
alors ça se fait avec pop ce qui permet
d'indiquer les valeurs pour lesquelles
on veut calculer nos différents quand il
l'a si je veux les gains tilt je
souhaite 00 20 04 06 08 et 1 et ça peut
se calculer rapidement avec 0,5 sur son
look
alors petite astuce pour apa
102.5 signifie 0 1 2 3 4 5
je fais 02 points 5 / 5 et bien
j'obtiens tout de suite 0 02 04 06 08 et
j'aurais pu aussi donner une série de
valeurs manuel je pourrais dire que je
venais quand il pour 10% 23% et sac
tout à fait un
valeur dans les fonctions
on retrouve aussi le minimum
le maximum
si on veut en une seule fois le minimum
et le maximum eh bien on a la fonction
one touch qui nous donne les valeurs
extrêmes
pardon
bien sûr dans les
tiens on va avoir aussi la variance dont
qui se calcule avec var en cours
m égal ou où l'écart type qui se calcule
avec sd pour standard déviation en
anglais ce qu'il faut
dans tous ces cas
vous avez les calculs qui sont
directement exécuté il s'affiche
simplement dans la console et
éventuellement et éventuellement vous
pourriez sauvegarder les résultats dans
un nouvel objet alors on peut aussi
avoir dans les fonctions vraiment
classique il est plus connu un petit
résumé tout ça grâce à marie donc si je
fais ce mari de trial âge donc se brise
d'une version générique qui permet en
fait en général d'avoir un résumé sur un
objet et si j'applique sur un lecteur
numérique j'ai très rapidement ici le
minimum le maximum les cartes il la
médiane la moyenne et le nombre de
valeurs manquantes
donc ça c'est les fonctions de base dont
air pour une variable quantitative
e
supposons que
variable catégorielles donc si je
entre on va refaire un petit look fort
de choix
on a par exemple
la variable stéitsch qui nous ont dit
que l'état d'avancement du concert avec
des valeurs qui sont t1 t2 t3 t4 qui les
forme textuelle et pour ça ce qu'on
calcule usuellement pour une variété
hâtive c'est un tableau de fréquences la
fonction de base dont air qui permet de
calculer un tableau de fréquences la
fonction table
donc si je fais table de crowd dollars
th
j'ai directement
lots de fréquences donc on avait
cinquante trois personnes au stade t1 54
et 2,43 t3 et 50 en t4 alors là on a
simplement en fait les effectifs
ah et il faut savoir qu'il ya une
deuxième fonction qui est de basware
qu'est la fonction iq stable elle se
présente juste un petit peu différemment
et ça va me permettre à produire la
notion de formule 1 je vous montre la
syntaxe et je vous explique ensuite ex
femme
on va écrire tilde alors le tilt des
petites virgules s'obtient sous un
clavier windows avec alger air et la
touche 2 la fonction ici qui n'intéresse
qui va être star et je vais indiqué
ensuite date à égal
or
tableau alors ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est à cette unique friture sous forme
de formule les formules ont les abordera
en particulier dans ce qu'on fera des
régression logistique
mais l'idée d'une formule c'est que
souvent à elles vont nous servir à à
décrire un modèle sous la forme d'une
variable explicative tilde et de moins
variable dépendante t-il variables
explicatives ici en fait on n'a pas de
variable dépendante on veut juste
d'écrire nos données en fonction de
variables stage est donc dans la syntaxe
6 tab
on va simplement donner cette écriture
de formule petite particularité
lorsqu'on écrit une formule on n'a pas
besoin de mettre des guillemets et en
fait à ce qui se passe que x table
comprend que ce stage est une des
variables deux toiles
en fait l'idée c'est qu'ici on va
comprendre des éléments de la formule de
l'ong contexte du tableau fois l'an
et puis enfin à
ce qu'on veut souvent quand on fait un
tableau donnait tout simple c'est
d'avoir aussi les pourcentages et donc
du coup ça peut se faire avec les
fonctions de base de herm et serq c'est
un petit peu compliqué et c'est pour ça
qu'on va avoir recours au package
cautionneur alors on va rajouter
cautionnaire ici au début et le chargé
en mémoire pascoe cautionnaire nous
fournit directement une fonction bien
pratique s'appelle fret et si je fais
freq toute forme
dollars âge eux
à mon âge
tout est ici direct
un tableau de fréquences avec du coup le
nombre d'observations les pourcentages
et 6 et 8 des valeurs manquantes nous
aurait indiqué aussi les valeurs
manquantes
l'intérêt c'est que ferait qu possède un
certain nombre d'options supplémentaires
notamment si je fais crunch où j'aurai
des pourcentages plus inactifs et si je
fais total et quelques faux j'aurai une
ligne total à l'affichage
alors on voit
déjà que la fonction feraient que nous
permet d'avoir une description un petit
peu plus propre de notre tableau de
frais commence mais toutes les fonctions
que l'on a vu jusqu'à présent
qui sont les fonctions de base à 2 r en
fait que ça fait ça nous renvoie un
objet qui s'imprime plus ou moins bien
dans la console
1 mais s'est affichée dans la console et
si j'essayais de copier ceux ci
je peux confier
sortie ici je lançais world
ce que j'obtiens
en un tableau
je vais vous collez le résultat
à
ce que l'on maintient en fait c
du texte est en fait les alignements son
générique des espacements là c'est pas
forcément bien visible si je prends une
police de caractère tels que courriers
qui sont des polices où chaque caractère
à la même largeur dont courrier
effectivement
1 on retrouve les bon alignement mais
c'est pas forcément quelque chose de
bien pratiquer une jolie sortie
alors c'est là où je vais vous présenter
le package geeti se marient donc
this mari je vous avoue une de mes
petites trouvailles 2020 c'est un
package qui va faciliter la création de
tableaux descriptif mais également de
tableaux de modèle et on va obtenir des
tableaux qui sont quasiment utilisé tel
quel dans des dents des articles
alors comme toujours un pour utiliser un
package qui n'est pas sous votre
ordinateur déjà il faut penser à
installer
donc pour installer je vous rappelle la
procédure vous allez en bas à droite
sous package vous cliquez sur install
mettez le nom du package
et ça va
package et installer les fichiers du
paquet sur votre ordinateur
pour rappel on a besoin d'un salaire
package uniquement la première fois
qu'on va l'utiliser ensuite les fichiers
du paquet jeux sont disponibles sur
votre pc
et pour l'utiliser dans un script par
contre et là chaque session il faut
penser à la charge en mémoire avec life
ball au lit vous voyez là au fur et à
mesure que je complexifie mon analyse
est que j'ai besoin d'un plus grand
nombre de package ce que je fais c'est
que je remets tout malice de package
nécessaire en début de mon script
alors l'intérêt de jean marie c qui
fournit une fonction qui permet de faire
des tableaux de description d'un
syndrome de variables avec la fonction
ti billard se marie donc je vais
marie la première
je vais faire c'est lui donner le nom
d'un fichier
d'un tableau
on est ici en l'occurrence prologue et
av
paramètre un cloud je vais indiquer les
variables que je veux affiché dans mon
tableau
là en l'occurrence la variable âge est
la variable stache
voyons voir
produits
alors voyez là le résultat ne s'affiche
pas
la console il s'affiche à droite
dans le temps dans le viewer est ce que
l'on a
là c'est un tableau qui est mise en
forme et que je peux maintenant copier
coller dans word
ah si je prends ce tableau là et que je
fais donc world
là j'ai pas pris on recommence
les droites copie je retourne dans word
ah mais pardon pour bien copie
cuz passe jamais te donnera directement
donc si on retourne dans les studios je
vais et cliquez sur ce petit bouton qui
va me permettre d'afficher sa dans le
navigateur web
j'ai mon tableau qui est copiée
le web dont google chrome là je vais le
copié depuis google chrome et je vais le
copier
dans world
il arrive à être copiée avec
bien un tableau qui arrive en sortie
alors par défaut
faible pour chacune des variables que
j'ai indiqué ici en l'occurrence state
ch1 je vais débarquer catégorielles sont
détectées automatiquement et il va faire
un tri à plat et pour les variables
numérique
il va il va présenter la médiane et
l'intervalle interquartile et s'il y en
a on nous indique le nom de valeurs
manquantes oui ici j'ai un oeil nonne
ont ce qui correspond au nombre de
valeurs manquantes 2 h s'il n'avait pas
mis le include ce que m'aurait fait
sybille se marie c'est qu'il aurait
sorti dans mon tableau l'ensemble des
variables présente dans thor alors comme
toyal ne contient que si cette variable
on a quelque chose qui est jouable mais
on aurait eu un tableau beaucoup plus
grans aurait été bien plus compliqué
alors on va également voir 2 3
sibilité que nous propose guy thys marie
première chose hein
là en l'occurrence comme air fonctionne
en fait à l'anglo-saxonne le tableau est
présenté en anglais et puis les
décimales sont indiquées par un point et
non par une vidéo
donc
maintenant que ce que je souhaite c'est
francisé un petit peu tout ça est alors
guy thys marie fonctionne avec un simple
de thèmes et donc je peux appeler thème
gîte ismérie langage je vais indiquer
comme langue français j'ai également
l'option décimales marque qui me permet
de personnaliser le marqueur de
décimales je mette la virgule et
byggmark qui permit est le marqueur de
milliers commencer par elle et tous les
trois nombres et je vais être un espace
alors la particularité d'un thème c'est
quand on met en place un thème ça va le
modifier pour toute la suite et donc en
fait c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai
besoin de sauvegarder en fait c'est
sauvegarder dans les options de verre
qui c'est pour ça que souvent les thèmes
on a plutôt tendance à les mettre au
tout début
un puisque je fais une personnalisation
qui va s'appliquer à l'ensemble de mon
script alors maintenant que j'ai défini
mon thème refaisons mon tableau
et voyez un certain nombre d'éléments ou
été traduit ici
alors autre élément qui
récent tibet elle se marie en fête
propose beaucoup d'options de
personnalisation là on voit aujourd'hui
comment faire des tableaux rapide et
simple avec ti benzema mais milliards à
plein de choses qu'on pourra faire par
contre on peut tout à fait indiquée des
étiquettes de variables on les avait
abordés très rapidement la semaine
dernière avec le package label d' ce que
je vais faire c'est juste après l'import
de données on va labelliser
quelques-unes des variables je vous
rappelle pour donner des étiquettes de
variables on peut avoir recours à vars
label donc supposons là que travailleur
et jh je vais le donner une étiquette
qui sera âge en année et puis
à traitement
on va refaire à général
que tu rct rt ici voilà donc reprenons
mes données depuis le début non je
versais à mon apport au propre
et junte
sauvegarde juste après ouvriers 1 comme
au fur et à mesure on va organiser le
code
donc je vous rappelle la fonction loupe
fort nous présente entre autres les noms
aussi les étiquettes sont directement
accessibles ici donc là j'ai mon
étiquette traitement et âge en année
alors je crois que dans le chatt
quelqu'un demandait s'il y avait une
différence entre look fort avec un
underscore et look fort attaché en fait
il y en a au plus non c'est la même
fonction elle est juste disponible dans
les deux orthographes look fort avec
lunch corse et c'est que c'est plus dans
la logique on va dire du taille d'hiver
sein d'ad de séparer en septième aux
paras par un séparateur et look fort
attaché c'est en référence à stata
puisque c'est une fonction qui s'inspire
beaucoup de tata qui a une fonction look
fort alors maintenant que j'ai des
étiquettes on voyons ce qui se passe si
je refais mon tableau de données dont je
reprends ma commande je la passe à la
console
et voyez ici à
pour les varia
comme âge l'étiquette a été prise en
compte pareil pour traitement autrement
dit lorsqu'on a mis les étiquettes de
variables sur des variables tibial ça
m'arrive à prendre en compte c'est
l'étiquette dans le tableau qui produit
et ça permet du coup facilement de
remplacer des codes technique par
quelque chose qui sera beaucoup plus
lisible
alors continuons un peu
ça
ristic vivarié quand on commence à
comparer deux variables entre elles
et pour à bord
et la satire
by varier le plus simple souvent c'est
de faire une exploration graphique
don
l air dispose de différentes fonctions
je vous avais dit un dans une session
précédente il ya tout un tas de
fonctions historiques dans aer qui
permettent de faire des graphiques même
si elles sont pas forcément très facile
à personnaliser ou pratique au quotidien
vous aviez eu historiquement un package
la tis qui fournit aussi de beaucoup de
fonctions graphiques et puis depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années à un
package qui s'est imposée c'est le
paquet de ggp lot
des pelotes vient du terme ramare of
coiffic il en fait j'ai pelote de a été
développé à partir de la grammaire des
graphiques qui a été un travail un peu
théorique composants d'une
représentation graphique de données nous
avons
rond dans de futures cessions l'ensemble
des possibilités de gp2 il serait en
soit possible de faire une dizaine ou
une douzaine
2 on pourrait faire une douzaine de
cession rien de sûr j'ai eu tellement il
est possible ce qu'on va voir
pour démarrer avec jean clottes 2 c'est
le package est-il fourni une interface
graphique pour pouvoir explorer les
données et générer du code vip lot 2
alors comme tout package 1 je voulais
dit il faut déjà à l'installer donc là
si je veux le package esquisses
je vais dans package
install l'installation du package esti
ce n'est requise que la toute première
fois histoire de disposer du package sur
son pc
le package
ni un admin on avait déjà abordé
rapidement aller a dit la semaine
dernière les add in ce sont des des
petites extensions ar studio et pour les
dispositifs hic le paquet de jeux soient
présents sur votre piscine et même pas
besoin de l'avoir chargé en mémoire avec
l'ail brebis et donc si je vais sur le
menu a dit non pour rappel c'est tout en
haut dans les airs studio et que je tape
f6 il y à 1 din que proposait steve et
qui s'appelle gjp lot 2 builder
alors quand on charge et ce qui est sa
première chose il va nous demander de
choisir un tableau de données parmi ceux
que l'on a actuellement dans
l'environnement
nous avons justement l'objet de faial en
mémoire dont je vais choisir twaron vous
avez la possibilité de ne retenir que
certaines des variables on a on nous dit
qu'il y avait but variable en tout il
détecte automatiquement les variables
type discrète et de type continue avec
leur valeur en compte
on va prendre toutes les variables par
par défaut il est possible à cette
étape-là de faire de la conversion on
n'a pas vraiment besoin et je vais
cliquez sur valider une porte et des
états
le principe de ggp lot c'est que sous
ggp lot un graphique s'obtient en
associant une variable à une esthétique
x la glaise xla que d y sont considérés
comme des esthétiques et vous avez deux
esthétiques comme s'ils couleurs de
remplissage la couleur que la couleur de
l'objet proprement dit size qui est la
taille d'un objet et on verra par la
suite ce que sont des facettes
par exemple supposons j'ai deux
variables numérique âge et kiev
je peux faire un
deux points en mettant âge en x et qui
jeff en y donc là sur ce gr
iq là j'ai représenté sur la liste est
la variable tdf et et au cinéma
numérique est représenté sur la dezir
est donc pour créer un graphique avec
ace qui sont va simplement faire glisser
ces variables au niveau d'une esthétique
en général esquissait va trouver le bon
type de graphique mais on peut tout à
fait le modifier ensuite ici en fonction
du type de variables que l'on a est par
exemple on va complexifier notre
graphique si je souhaitais par exemple
que la couleur de mes points dépendent
du grade
et donc je
et wad sur color et voyez maintenant la
couleur de mes points va dépendre de la
variable canada
j'aurais pu
une représenté sur l'axé y non pas une
variable au numérique mais plutôt une
variable peuvent être le traitement y
et rester
un nuage
oui alors vu que là en
j'ai mis une variable qui est
catégorielle et quand x j'ai mis une
variable qui est continu par défaut
esquisse m'a plutôt nous proposer des
boîtes à moustache comme représentation
graphique qui permet de comparer du coup
les différentes variables
alors si je retire gratte de color
là je me retrouve un
si coup j'ai une
moustache pour la drogue a est une boîte
à moustache pour la drogue b pour rappel
dans une boîte à moustache le gros
traits du milieu c'est la médiane la
taille du rectangle correspond aux
premiers quartiers l'eau deuxième carte
il
vous avez ici le maximum et le minimum
alors ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il
est ce qu'ils sont c'est qu'on peut
facilement jouer avec les données et
avec les différents types de
représentations graphiques et on arrive
tout de suite avoir quelque chose qui
qui fonctionne alors revoyons ensemble
qu'elles sont de manière un peu plus
systématique
quels sont les types de représentations
graphiques que l'on a en statistiques
descriptives
si j'ai une seule variable quantitative
par exemple l'âge une bonne reprise
physique c'est ce qu'on appelle un
histogramme l'histogramme vous est
représentée ici d'accord donc on a l'âge
ou représentés ici sur l' axe
dx et on a pour chacun des petits
rectangles une une barre qui représente
le nombre d'observations
alors si je clique sur pelote options on
va
un certain nombre d'options qui nous
sont proposées notamment je peux réduire
le nombre de binz
alors ce qu'ils appellent binz ici c'est
le nombre c'est le le nombre de barres
verticales d'accord donc je peux avoir
un histogramme qui va être plus ou moins
fins plus ou moins lycée mais c'est la
présentation classique est recommandé
quand on a une seule variable
quantitative
quand on a une variable catégorielles je
me demande d'ailleurs qu'on propose par
défaut ici ce qu'on va
si c'est simplement un graphique en
barres avec le nombre d'observations
dans chacune des modalités donc là on a
à peu près 76 personnes qui ont reçu le
traitement à et à peu près autant qu'ils
ont reçu le traitement b si je prends
une variable différentes à la variable
wade
voilà sur une variable qui est plutôt
bien structuré entre entre les
différentes modalités
quand je cherche maintenant à comparer
deux variables
on peut avoir trois cas de figure
premier cas de figure je vais avoir deux
variables qui sont numériques pour ça le
meilleur type de graphique en général
c'est de représenter une variable sur la
cx l'autre variable sur la kz2 y est
d'avoir un nuage de points pour essayer
de voir si on a une corrélation entre
les deux variables qui nous intéresse il
faut savoir que dans ce cas là quand
vous faites un nuage plein de points non
peu d'options vous avez la possibilité
ici de cliquer sur ce mot fly
qui normalement va calculer
automatiquement alors pas une droite de
régression mais plutôt une en fait ce
sont des regrets sur le cas mais qui
nous permet d'aborder dans sens de la
relation entre nos deux variables et là
on voit effectivement que la variable
tdf ne varie pas n'est pas ne semble pas
corrélées est invariable âge
lorsque l'on a
une variable numé
et une variable catégorielles une des
représentations classiques de
comparaison c'est de réaliser des boîtes
à moustache donc revenons du bois ta
moustache cheveux v
regardez comment l'âge évolue en
fonction du stage
et donc la source
pouvoir une augmentation graphique dit
de bois ta moustache
l'âge qui représentait en eau et pour
chacun des 4 et il semble que les gens
t3 soit légèrement plus âgés que t1 mais
voyez les distinctions sont relativement
faibles
une représentation alternative aux
boîtes à moustache c'est la présentation
dit
violin
qui vous représente
chiant de manière symétrique des deux
côtés donc là encore on voit qu'il ya un
petit les gens et trois sont légèrement
plus âgés que les gens t1 mais encore
une fois c'est plutôt attirés dans
chacune des catégories klein
alors qui est intéressant
pelote de builder c'est qu'on peut
commencer à faire des graphiques un
petit peu plus compliqué si je reviens
sur mes boîtes à moustache que j'avais
juste avant donc âge en y et stitch en x
je peux commencer à vouloir comparer
avec une troisième varia pas raison qui
serait le traitement et si jamais sur
fils fils c'est un paramètre qui
contrôle la couleur de remplissage de
mes objets voyez là je me retrouve pour
chacun des pour chacune des modalités de
stage en bas avec une boîte à moustache
différentes
une manière de faire ça c'est de le
faire avec des facettes
alors le principe d'une phase s est de
faire en fait des graphiques les uns à
côté des autres facettes flou ça veut
dire que je vais faire deux sérigraphies
qu'une première série pour de ouaga et
une pour gwatt be facettes faut ça me le
fait en ligne alors que facet colle ça
me ferait
côte à côte
parce que est ce que c'est ce que je
n'est on verra dans une session dédiée a
jugé claude de 1 comment est ce qu'on
fait tout ça avec du code plus précis
l'intérêt que vous avez ici c'est
quelqu'un faire face des esquisses on
peut commencer à avoir des graphiques de
manière un peu intuitive vous avez sous
l'onglet label et eichhof la possibilité
d'ajouter un titre au graphique
un sous titre
cette légende donc en quête 2020 et vous
pouvez aussi personnel de la clinique
c'est dax et y donc en fait on a
possibilité sur la balle et ishares de
changer les étiquettes du graphique sur
plateau ption vous avez des éléments
additionnels par exemple si je remets le
traitement dans cl voyez là que la
légende par défaut et à droite je peux
mettre la légende en bas l'onglet
à vous fournit des options pour limiter
en fait
l'échantillon c'est à dire je pourrais
dire je ne voudrais inclure dans
graphique que t1 t2 t3 et t4 est retiré
du coup les individus qui sont et 4 et
ensuite ce qui nous intéresse en
particulier c
loncle
export en code qui vous donne le code
correspondant pour faire le graphique et
vous avez un bouton copier toutes les
bourdes
donc je vais
simon code
et je vais aller le copier
dans
et de générer le graphique que nous
avons vu
alors aujourd'hui nous n'enverrons pas
plus en terre
deux graphiques avec j -p lot 2 nous
aurons une séance entière dédiée sur
comment est ce que l'on fait des
graphiques et que j'ai belote 2 qu'est
ce que veut dire la fonction ggp lot
à quoi correspond la fonction avait ce
qu'est ce que sont que les fonctions de
type g hommes et fonctions scale et des
fonctions de thèmes là nous n'avons pas
le temps de voir tous ces éléments-là en
détail mais voyez avec le package
esquisse un jour et que je vous rappelle
en charge paquet pestis depuis de nadine
on peut commencer à explorer
visuellement ces données de manière
intuitive et on peut récupérer le code
correspondant
un graphique
alors je regarde
sont posées
on nous demande est ce compte
hier sous forme de pdf ci pourra les
exploiter sous forme de pdf on abordera
ça un petit peu plus tard la fonction
offline
alors la fonction spoof line en fait
c'est le recours à une géométrie qui
s'appelle james bof si vous voulez plus
d'information on pouvait regarder l'aide
de jérôme bosch
et ce 7 jours il a à plusieurs méthodes
la méthode par défaut en fête repose sur
la méthode l' os alors on va pas aller
plus avant ici mais si vous êtes
intéressés pour savoir comment sont
calculées les courbes de jeunes sauf à
les regarder du coup l'aide de la
fonction j'aime ce mot
alors
un violon une contrebasse pour la
géométrie violin elle s'appelle marine
est en fait tout dépend des
distributions sur la forme que l'on
prend la pyramide
alors la pyramide des âges ne peut pas
être calculé avec esquisse pour faire
des pyramides des âges c'est à dire vous
avez un graphique en barres avec des
barres vers la gauche pour les hommes
débarquent à droite pour les femmes il
faut être sûr des choses déjà un peu
plus avancé donc on n'abordera pas
aujourd'hui
à
et dernière question c'est est il
possible d'organiser les bâtons d'un
histogramme par ordre croissant des
croissants la réponse est non
comment vont alors juste pour rapidement
un pour faire la distinction entre un
graphique en barres et un graphique à un
histogramme 1
on suppose
vouziers ce graphique là
là on a un graphique en barres en valeur
1 2 et 3 et on est sur des parieurs
catégorielles il serait tout à fait
possible décidé de changer l'ordre des
différentes part entre la gauche et la
droite pour représenter pour représenter
nos valeurs par contre lorsque l'on est
sur un histogramme
et
bien dans un an
programme les valeurs en fait ce bâton
la correspond découpage entre 31 et 33
ans et donc l'ordre des bâtons de
l'histogramme sont dans l'ordre de la
variable que l'on a découpé donc sur un
histogramme ya pas du tout question
d'ordonnancement puisqu'en fait tout oui
bien tous les bâtons se touchent les uns
les autres
voilà et ce qui compte dans un
histogramme ce n'est pas la notion de
bâton et la notion de superficie et la
forme de cette cour si on regarde si je
diminue le nombre de bibs par exemple en
fait on a une même forme globale mais la
forme elle ne change pas
fondamentalement et je pourrait
augmenter
bon nombre de milles qui voit là
/ 10 / g c'est cette une soeur
d'approximations de la courbe de densité
d'une distribution
allez
or ce que je vous propose
c'est de voir quelques options
supplémentaires du tibia mari pour
pouvoir faire des tableaux croisés
vous l'avez vu ainsi je prends la faune
ce mari et que je lui passe tout un
objet qui est en l'occurrence ici trois
ans
steve sur chacune des variables
mais
je peux passer aux paramètres by le
nombre d'une variable que je souhaite
comparer pour l'ensemble de des autres
variables
on va prendre l'exemple ici je fais
tibet al samaoui trial by égal thierry
pour la variable traitement
et à ce moment là vous voyez ce que je
un j'obtiens
tableau avec une colonne pour jack à une
colonne pour doc b&g tous les éléments
qui sont indiqués j'ai ma comparaison de
tous les autres variables que jenny de
dons si j'avais voulu faire quelque
chose d'un peu plus consistent à dire ne
pas avoir toutes les variables je
pourrais jouer que paramètres un club
pour dire seulement les variables que je
sois de boire dans mon tableau
et il ya d'autres élèves
pouvoir encore personnalisés
premièrement la ce qui met affichée
alors
sur plusieurs lignes les commandes de
tibias se marrer pour s'asseoir un petit
peu plus lisible ce que l'on voit c'est
que les pourcentages qui sont affichées
sur des posters en colonne 29 +26 plus
22-23 égale 100% je souhaiterais
éventuellement à ce que les pourcentages
qui soient affichés sur des pourcentages
en ligne
je dispose d'une option qui s'appelle
personne égale roues
et avec cette option là gérant ps
aimer pourcentage envoyé ici effectifs %
par des pourcentages en ligne
je voudrais aussi éventuellement plutôt
que d'avoir la médiane et l'intervalle
interquartile je préférais pour les
variables numérique avoir plutôt la
moyenne et l'écart titre
alors on peut faire ça
à deux options pour faire ça vous
présente la première nous avons un
paramètre qui s'appelle statistiques
alors là ça te fait un petit peu
compliqué au début donc surtout 1
retenez bien la syntaxe est si belle se
marier pour un débutant peut sembler
parfois un peu atypique mais en fait
avec statistiques on peut dire
précisément ce que l'on a envie et à
satisfont à lui a passé une liste et ce
qui est attendu ces noms de variables
tilde statistiques attendues
sauf que là ce qu'on veut c'est modifier
toutes les variables numérique en une
fois et on a un raccourci qui s'appelle
au continuo ce alors ça ne marche que
dans jeet is marie-mai qui peut se dire
toutes les variables continue until
death et on va indiquer sous forme
textuelle des statistiques que l'on veut
alors je
il ment l'aide de tibial son mari
parce que c'est ici
y est possible
et notamment
voilà pour les variables continue on
peut dire médiane mines sd farmine max
et 0,3 pour le personnes t-il à trois
points sont payées 25 pour premier kart
il et on peut même passer n'importe quel
type de fonction qui nous intéresse donc
par exemple si je veux représenter la
moyenne est entre parenthèses l'écart
type on veut écrire mines
alors oui mais il est indiqué entre
accolade ski jeunes entre parenthèses et
ch'ti
et donc ça va
un tableau
pour les variables continue
sont pas représentés la moyenne est
entre parenthèses les quartiers
alors cette forte on a syntaxe ici s'il
syntaxe l'on reverra un notamment avec
la fonction glu pour la gestion de
chaînes de caractères en fait c'est que
ça nous permet d'utiliser entre
accolades un nombre variable et le reste
c'est le chemin
supposons que j'aurais plutôt voulu
écrire mètres entre crochets et puis en
fait que ça soit ôtée de points égal
la hotte et est compris comme un
mon de l'affichage
alors puisqu'ils émir entre accolades et
compris comme une variable calculé qu'il
va falloir remplacer
alors un autre
e
exemple j'aurais pu dire par exemple que
je veux la médiane on peut me
m med 2 points sache moins de points
pour avoir la médiane et la moyenne
donc en fait la grande
or si si c'est qu'on peut vraiment pas
recettes divisées à l'envi le tableau
que l'on présente
l'âge et la médiane et la moyenne
chez pour les variables qui sont
numériques chose même encore un peu plus
folle si vous regardez le pied du
tableau eh bien il voyait sa s'actualise
il me dit mais deux points médiane moins
de moyenne donc en fait on a même un
pied de tableau qui ce qui s'actualise
en fonction alors si on veut simplement
basculer un par défaut on est sûr
médiane intervalle interquartile et si
ce que l'on veut c'est avant tout la
moyenne et l'écart type on peut aller
plus rapidement avec thème jean marie
mines sd qui permet de changer ça de
manière globale et quand on fait le
tableau par défaut sauf si on a défini
statistiques on aura
à
[Musique]
tic voulu
quelques petits éléments à
on peut aussi vouloir contrôler le
nombre le nombre de chiffres après la
virgule et ça se fait qu'argument ids
ips
alors là par exemple voyez pour les
variables ils sont catégorielles on a un
effectif suivi d'un pourcentage est en
fait par défaut on a une précision qui
est plus ou moins une décimale suivant
les cas de figure le 5 % email 0 mais
pas sur 46 % si je veux contrôler
partout un certain nombre de deux
chiffres après la virgule
encore une fois on doit passer une liste
puis on veut variable là je veux faire
quelque chose pour toutes les variables
catégorielles donc on va les chercher
or la catégorie cros field
et alors
un nombre de valeurs qui dépend du
nombre d'éléments statistiques affichées
lavoyer par défaut pour les bars et
catégorielles on a un effectif et une
deuxième valeur qui est un pourcentage
je vais indiquer ses 0 1 pour dire le
premier chiffre ici l'effectif je ne
veux pas de chiffres après la virgule
deuxième chiffres pourcentages je veux
un chiffre après la virgule
et je pourrais aussi du coup forcé pour
les variables numérique alors comme
c'est une moyenne un écart type j'ai
envie de dire que par défaut ça serait
bien qu'ils aient au moins
systématiquement un chiffres après la
virgule est donc fort au continuo ce je
vais indiquer ses
cullin gerland
alors vous inquiétez pas inconscient
d'un gros tableaux de données où
beaucoup de variables ça prend parfois
un petit peu de temps ça dépend de la
puissance de votre pc
et voilà quelques secondes mais notre
tableau commence à prendre forme
alors parfois il peut être très utile
d'avoir aussi une colonne total
et ça
ce faire assez facilement avec la
fonction
add
faux
or si je regarde l'aide de la fonction à
taux frôle l propre milieu un objet x
qui est le tableau retourner parmi elles
se marient
donc techniquement il faut que je prenne
tout mon tableau ici et que je le passe
à ado vaut ce qui pourrait se faire
en écrivant had aux rôles et dans la
parenthèse je mets tout mon tableau
regardons résultats vincent
appliquée à d'autres volets donc ça m'a
rajouté une colonne total avec
l'ensemble des individus alors 7
là et pas forcément facile à lire et je
veux juste rapidement vous introduire
quelque chose auquel on va revenir
beaucoup dans les prochaines sessions
c'est le fameux palpe introduit par le
tailles diverses
alors le pape c'est le symbole pour cent
supérieur bon sens
d'accord pour comprendre ce que ça veut
dire
quand vous
v x hype f2 y c est
non
à f
2 x y y
l'intérêt c'est que ça va permettre
d'avoir des écritures beaucoup plus
simple vous voyez cette commande là
je peux la réécrire en disant je prends
l'objet de fraudes
j'applique
on subit elle se marie alors mai
by égale trt personnes
et
et on avait le dj tz
et tout ça
je vais rajouter là-dessus had au pot
peut paraître c'est un
bizarre au début donc retenir que x
f2i y c'est équivalent à f2 xy
mais ça permet du coup quand on a des
fonctions qui vont s'appliquer à chaque
fois sur le résultat de la précédente de
pouvoir gagner en fait dans une syntaxe
est plus visible puisque on va voir les
étapes une par une
d'accord donc ça
le remplacer par ceux ci
et donc là on
l'effet du adopo
et puis je
ajouter une petite option vous avez
l'ast qui permet si j'utilise la stegall
flou ça va me permettre
de le positionner non pas au début mais
ma colonne total à la fin
alors
je vois deux questions
lle sur tibet le mari peut-on obtenir un
retour à la ligne anti bio se marie par
exemple avoir la moyenne sur une ligne
est juste en dessous l'écart type
la réponse est oui il y a une technique
qui permet à l'or
le mieux c'est d'aller au retour
et avoir l'aide de jets 6 marie alors
ici vous renvoie vers le site un de
justice mari quand on va sur le site de
cheat ismaily
vous avez remarqué
un rite orient
une des possibilités en fait qu'un
produit du 10 mai pour des variables
continue multi line continue à saint
mary's
il est présenté ici l'idée c'est que on
va dire est que taipei que toutes les
variables continue seront du type n'ont
pas continué mais continue ou deux et on
va pouvoir du coup indiqué des
statistiques comme une liste de
différents éléments donc là ça serait
une première ligne via le nombre de noms
manquants oui la médiane avec internet
interquartile puis le minimum et le
maximum et vous pouvez du coup faire ce
type de tableau là où pour les variables
qui sont qui sont continus vous avez des
statistiques présentées sur plusieurs
lignes au dessus
qui est posée peut-on triés par
plusieurs variables en utilisant bayal
c'est varin var 2 alors non bail ne peut
prendre une seule variable
ceci étant dit si vraiment vous voulez
faire des choses qui sont avancés on a
une possibilité de fusionner deux
tableaux ensemble avec la fonction tbl
ce pack est donc avec tbl stack vous
pourriez faire un tableau pour la
variable une puis un tableau pour la
variable 2 et ensuite mettre les deux
tableaux côte à côte
bon c'est pas telle taxe était d'aylmer
m
blu l'un au dessus de l'autre des belles
mères pour votre tableau à droite l'un à
l'autre
vous avez ici un fois les attendait dans
les exemples mais on va essayer de faire
un essai table je vais faire un premier
tableau qui va être tibia choya et mon
tableau fait sauvegarder
ici tu es d'accord donc tibial se marie
donc là je vais comparer pour la donc
égal c'est trt est ce que je veux
comparer c'est la variable âge est la
variable grade by traitement
puis je vais faire un deuxième table
je vais comparer cette fois-ci non pas
par traitement mais par th
donc il faut que j'inclus stage dans mon
tableau et ça devrait t2 donc j'ai mal
et un tableau t2
et normalement
un petit billet l'mage de t1 et t2
ah pardon
tu es belle mère
liszt créé un t2 et là vous avez du coup
un tableau je vais faire un saut après
soit plus visible
j'ai mon premier tableau mon deuxième
tableau et qui sont fusionnés en un seul
grand tableau ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que là ce soir je vous présente
vraiment les bases du package 10 marie
voyer qu'on peut aller très très loin
ce qui est important à savoir c'est que
dans tout ce qu'on va faire avec r il
est notamment axé package qui nous
fournissent des éléments pour se
faciliter la vie
on peut faire rapidement des choses à
propre et propres nécessaires exactement
le tableau vous voulez ça nécessite pas
mal de code
donc ce qui va être important c'est
vraiment où est ce que vous en êtes dans
votre programmation de m6 ce qu au delà
ou semble déjà compliqué il vaut mieux
ne pas aller trop loin et rajouter
l'option au fur et à mesure
alors revenons à notre tableau précédent
celui-ci
alors ce tableau là
nos différentes variables en comparant
le groupe drogue à et le groupe doive by
d'accord et la colonne total ce que l'on
aimerait avoir c
à faire des tests de comparaison pour
savoir est-ce que l'âge moyen diffère
significativement entre le groupe drogue
à et le groupe droite be de même est ce
que la distribution partage ou la
distribution par grade diffère entre nos
deux groupes
ça revient à faire des tests de
comparaison statistique
on pourrait passer beaucoup de temps à
faire un cours de statistiques ce n'est
pas le webinaire à savoir quels sont les
types de tests à faire à retenir quand
on veut comparer deux variables
catégorielles on aura deux manière
générale recours aux thèses du chi 2 et
pour un tableau de 2 et votre montes de
fisher et quand on veut comparer et
variables eu plusieurs des variables
numérique entre différents groupes
on a soit un test de comparaison des
médianes qui al'avantage d'être un test
non paramétriques et qui ne présuppose
pas qu'on a des distributions normal ou
si on suppose qu'on a des distributions
normal on aura recours à tester de sud
est qui intéressant si vous êtes
intéressés par les différentes fonctions
pour faire ses différents tests
je vous invite à aller
sur le site analyse airs et sur le site
analyseur on nous vous avez notamment un
chapitre sur les tests de comparaison
comparaison moyen des proportions et qui
vous présente les différents types de
tests et comme lorsqu'on et réalise un
test et de studen se fait que la
fonction des pointes est si je reviens à
tibial se marie on peut avoir rapidement
pas
alors choix que font
1 donc si on revient
1 / a
le package tibial son mari pour ajouté
des tests de comparaison à un tableau il
suffit simplement de rajouter at paie
donc comme tout
là j'ai recours au pape pour enchaîner
en fait l'appel aux différents types de
fonctions et si je fais mon tableau en
ayant rajouté at t à la feinte
le tableau s'est rajouté et nous avons
des
alors qu'ils ont été rajoutés autrement
dit sion d'une valeur de 0,8
on est largement au-dessus des 5% donc
ya pas de différence d'âge entre les
deux groupes
et si on veut savoir les tests réalisés
vous les avez directement en bas alors
par défaut
à
si bien se marient réalise un test duty
2 pour des variables catégorielles et un
test de comparaison de médiane pour les
variables
catégorie yale sauf si vous avez
appliqué tm du tice bah oui mini sd
puisque dans ce cas là ce qui est
présenté ce ne sont plus les médias
mais les moyennes aider dans ces cas là
c'est un test t2 sud yen qui est réalisé
si vous voulez avoir plus de contrôle
vous pouvez les voir l'aide de la
fonction hp pour tibial sonnerie
et vous avez le choix du coup d'indiquer
le type de test que vous voulez pas là
puisque vous avez à votre disposition le
texte et de sundance le la nova
unidimensionnel un test de gaulle coxon
des rangs cette thèse de comparaison des
mails et des médias le test de cruscades
loire et de wallis donc vous pouvez
aller plus loin dans le contrôle des
tests de comparaison mais sinon de
manière générale vous avez pas vous
occuper un de base vous avez l'été ceux
les plus courants et les plus pratiques
qui pourraient avoir très rapidement
pour montrer encore une fois ça un
tableau
comment utilisable avec des tests de
comparaison et qui résume bien vos
différents groupes
alors dont les questions est ce que le
script
du webinaire hui le script sera
disponible sur le site de webinaires je
vous mettrai tout à l'heure à la fin de
la session jeu
il ya un certain nombre de problèmes
d'installation package sous mac alors je
suis pas utilisateurs de mac serait pas
forcément vous aider ce que je vous
recommande néanmoins pour toute
prestation de package c'est de vérifier
déjà si vous avez la dernière version de
r la dernière version de leur studio et
tous ces éléments là seront des choses
que l'on pourra discuter la semaine
prochaine puisque nous aurons une
session particulière de déploiera
question qui aura lieu sur zoom les
liens de connexion seront envoyées par
e-mail avant et donc du coup on pourrait
être en échange direct et aborder ce
genre de prêt me précis est ce qu'il
existe un équivalent testis pour
utiliser des cartes malheureusement pas
à ma connaissance on peut faire des
cartes de manière assez poussées avec
gégé pelote de avec d'autres package
je ne sais pas si on aura l'occasion de
faire un webinaire là dessus mais encore
une fois on arrive sur des choses qui
sont bien plus avancés il a géré on est
encore vraiment qu'au tout début
alors
catherine galec comment appliquer tille
al samaoui sur des données d'enquêté
avec des pondérations alors il faut
savoir que lorsque l'on à des données
denquête avec pondération souvent on se
contente d'appliquer les poids de l'anc
est normalement il faut aussi tenir
compte du fait que ça soit et donc être
stratifié et où on craint pour ça il
faut avoir
il faut définir en fait un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe puisque si la
pondération doit être prise en compte
pour le calcul de médiane de pourcentage
tout ce qui est calcul de variance doit
lui prendre en compte également le plan
d'échantillonnage complexe j'aurais pas
le temps de l'aborder aujourd'hui et on
aura une session dédiée là dessus sur ce
cas particulier de ces enquêtes
kir tiers d'utiliser package serait le
package servais est vraiment fait pour
qu'on va prendre un jeu de données et on
va pouvoir définir du coup le plan
d'échantillonnage qui s'applique c'est à
dire ce qu'on a des strates est-ce qu'on
a des grappes et quels sont les
pondérations et il se trouve que
d'antibes il yal dandy qui se marient
depuis l'été dernier c'était pour tout
vous dire ça a été mon de mes
occupations du premier confinement qui a
été de développer la fonction tibill sv
se marie donc vous avez en fait
dans le betis mari une fonction qui
s'avale tibet et samarie qui fait
exactement les mêmes choses que tibet
elles se marient sauf qu'elle prend en
compte du coup l'ensemble des
pondérations et pour les tests
statistiques
vous avez donc du coup ci est râpé qui
est disponible pour tibet se marie sauf
qu'on est sur une autre série de tests
statistiques puisqu'ils prennent en
compte les plantes échantillonnage
complexe que ce soit le thé le test est
adaptée à ces situations où les tests
rang adapté donc voilà donc vous avez
aussi tous les éléments possibles pour
des enquêtes avec modération mais on
arrive en fait sur des choses un peu
plus compliqué et dans courant de
l'année prochaine on fera une session
vraiment dédié aux enquêtes complexes
pour voir comment est-ce qu'on adapte
l'analyse statistique la régression
logistique et la question des graffitis
alors est ce que l'argument h
tient compte des conditions de validité
pour le choix des tests par défaut qui
fait alors je vais vous dire non mais
petite précision par défaut tibial se
marient vous présente les médianes
l'intervalle interquartile et par défaut
le test utilisé
c'est justement le test c'est le fps de
comparaison des médias non paramétriques
et je sais plus s'il utilise wilcox ou
le crous call par défaut
sun qui est utilisé l'intérêt c'est que
le test de huy coxon de comparaison des
rangs n'a pas de conditions de validité
particulière il peut fonctionner long
par 2 médiane 3 médiane 4 médiane hausse
médiane et donc du coup et les peut
fonctionner indépendamment d'hypothèses
sur la normalité ou non des variables si
des distributions sont pas normales le
test de l'autre auxonne est toujours
valable
de même le taïkido est un test qui ne
fait pas d'hypothèse même s'il ya une
petite condition de validité qui est
s'assurer qu'on appelle des effectifs
théoriques supérieure à 5
donc les les choix par défaut de tibet
al-shammari sont des choix par défaut
qui fonctionne dans la quasi totalité
des cas si vous passez avec thème qui se
marie mines sd et que vous souhaitez
présenter des moyennes et comparer des
moyennes cogitis mari ne fait pas le
travail de vérification des hypothèses
sous jacentes donc autrement dit vous
savez ce que vous faites
enfin et encore une fois titi c'est ma
vie ça fait partie des package qui sont
là pour aider à faire les tableaux mais
pas faire des statistiques à votre place
est normalement vous devriez vérifier la
normalité
si vous voulez regarder ça plus en
détails je vous invite à aller justement
sur un analyseur et sur le test de
comparaison moyenne puisqu'on revient
justement pour la comparaison moyenne
sur les tests normalité est normalement
le test de shapiro qui permet de
vérifier si vos distribution sont
normales et si du coup on peut se
permettre de faire un test t il n'y a
pas de vérification automatique par la
fonction at pays
alors
am
pour finir je
vous présentez une dernière petite
fonction on voit tibial se marient
permet quand même de faire la plupart
des tableaux de base entre n'a besoin
que ce soit tableau purement univariée
ou un tableau by varier de manière très
simple et voyez qu'on peut rajouter
rapidement les tests de combat de
comparaison et d'épée valeur on l'a vu
le package et stis vous permet de
commencer à jongler un petit peu avec
des pelotes 2 et a essayé de faire
ensemble de graphiques
je veux juste me représenter un dernier
petit graphique d'un autre package qui
lui la librairie gg galli vous pouvez
rajouter
gg
ali
et
moir alors j'ai gagné un package qui
fournit quelques mets ta fonction pour
faire des graphiques un petit peu plus
compliqué avec gégé pelote 2 et
notamment ce qui va nous intéresser ici
c'est la fonction jbe var y est
alors l'inter
fonction gibert y est c'est d'avoir un
peu la même chose vis belle ce qu'on a
fait avec un petit billet elle se marie
pour taire pour traitement c'est-à-dire
pourra regarder comment varier un
certain nombre de variables
alors j'y vis variétés
on va d'abord lui passer des données en
l'occurrence croyants dont on va définir
ont validé le nom d'une variable de type
outcome là on va utiliser traitement et
puis on va dire les variables
explicatives que l'on souhaite regarder
on va prendre âge stage et gradins
alors vous voyez par défaut les valeurs
tirer et qu'est ce que nous fait j'y
mets variés de basse nous fait
rapidement un graphique vous voyez ici
j'ai cliqué sur zoom et ce graphique
nous permet de voir comment âge varie en
fonction de stages et de grade
donc là j'ai passé une variable
catégorielles comme variable date comme
âge est une variable est une variable
continu non par défaut ils nous
proposent des bottes au stage de
comparaison et pour ce stage est pour
grade
on nous a présenté ici par défaut
des comparaisons sous forme de
diagrammes anbar cumulé horizontal et
vous avez du coup les pourcentages qui
sont indiqués encore une fois j'ai jb
variété pas forcément un graphique
une fonction qui est de faire des
graphiques de qualité parfaite pour une
publication par contre ça permettrait
rapidement de nous pouvoir garder un
certain nombre de choses et puis autre
fonction qu'on va trouver et qui me faut
mentionner un conte va on va trouver
dans gg galli c'est la fonction
gg table qui permet
gg table se présente
hamon
donc on lui
ni
à
alors on
qu'en fait les colonnes en x et les
colonnes on y tient pas qu'à un tout
petit peu différente mais c'est un peu
le même principe donc je vais dire trt
en x colonnes y donc dans le cas présent
je pourrais mettre un deux variables en
colonnes par exemple traitement et
stitch et henry
qui m
âge
enfin ces âges et grades
alors je dois
1 une erreur car
ici
c'est pas seulement bon endroit là
donc j'étais à blain par défaut
vous faites sur deux tableaux croisés
s'est plutôt fait pour des variables
catégorielles mais quand vous n'avez pas
du coup
mais vous pouvez du coup il met malgré
tout des variables de type numérique
dans ce cas là il va nous présenter
plutôt les médianes ce qui est
intéressant d'en gérer table alors je
vais vous remettre le code 1 de manière
un peu plus visible c'est qu'on va
pouvoir personnaliser ce qui est
représenté sur le graphique
donc pour ça je ne connais jamais mais
je vais je me suis regardée en fait
l'aide de la fonction et notamment vous
avez le paramètre sauce qui permet de
dire qu'est ce qu'on veut représenter
dans l'est dans les cellules
moi ce que je veux voir céder
pourcentage en ligne
kobo pop et puis on vous propose aussi
de changer la couleur de remplissage et
notamment on va pouvoir représenter des
résidus du petit 2
alors pour ceux qui connaissent un
artistique un les résidus duty 2 c'est
un outil alors je vais retirer la
variable agen pour faciliter la lecture
voilà les résidus du petit 2 ça permet
de représenter
pourquoi j'ai pas la légende
[Musique]
oh
si je
et plus tôt
jamais deux stages en ligne pour
faciliter la lecture donc les résidus du
t2 et j'ai toujours pas de légende
normalement à 6 en fait ça vous
affichant en rouge ou en bleu les
cellules qui ont qui je vais reprendre
un exemple sur analysait qui s'écartent
en fait c'est en fait très visible quand
on est sur des cas de figure où vous
avez une forte corrélation et ça
pourrait devoir en fait les six bons
risques du kid et sont très positifs à
vous dire qu'en fait vous avez une
surreprésentation dans cette cellule
s'ils sont très négatifs vous avez une
sous-représentation et s'est déjoué du
direct c'est toujours là où vous avez
quelque chose qui ne marche pas
forcément très bien on va revenir sur
l'analyseur intègre les fonctions on
doit avoir un exemple plus parlant donc
ça
j'ai table alors
g tap elle a abordé du coup donc
et variés bavaria que j'ai plus de 2 g
table voilà la ronde à voir ici vous
en plus visible donc avec j'établis 6
on représente dans un autre fichier de
données mais on compare ici en fait le
fait de pratiquer du sport sur du sexe
du fait du niveau d'études et du fait de
pratiquer la cuisine et vous avez ici
des résidus qui deux qui sont positifs
en bleu est négatif en rouge et en
général on considère à et alors je vois
que des commentaires sur le fait que pas
de légende c'est peut-être dû à la
taille de la fta du graphique en
l'agrandissant doigt la voie alors je
pense qu' il s' il ya deux choses quand
il n'y a pas du tout des faits la
légende est pas visible sinon peu qui
est en fait là c'est qu'il faut
comprendre c'est des graphiques qui sont
combinés entre eux on peut choisir sur
quel graphique on la récupère et
effectivement il se trouve que comme je
suis en train de stream et mon écran mon
écran et en résolution plus faible que
d'ordinaire
jean taille de grâce et qui est un peu
plus petit ceci étant dit voilà ici sur
ce graphique là ce que vous pouvez voir
c'est que vous avez ici cuisine oui et
sports wii et on est en bleu et alors et
sport non et cuisinons sont six en bleu
ce que ça veut dire que c'est que les
gens qui font de la cuisine france plus
souvent du sport et que en fait les
associations oui oui et non noms sont
sur représentés par contre on peut voir
ici que les femmes font moins de sport
que des hommes et ça se voit par le fait
que la cellule homme sport est en bleu
donc on un résidu positif alors que là
cela sa douleur sam sport oui un résidu
du chi de négatif donc en fait c'est un
outil qui peut être intéressant dans une
phase exploratoire de regarder les
résidus qui 2 faut toujours être
vigilant selon l'interprétation mais ça
peut permettre de donner des idées de où
est ce que l'on commence à voir des
associations à cette étape exploratoire
alors
pour finir eux
nous aurons si l'année prochaine une
session dédiée à et remarques down père
marc daun c'est un outil qui permet de
faire des rapports
automatisée avec rr studio que ce soit
au format word au format excel ou au
format pdf au format html par exemple
l'ensemble du si d'analyseurs est écrit
en vers markdown de même que le site web
in r acétate là on est encore j'ai envie
de dire après notre troisième session du
webinaire encore des débutants
mais si on a fait un script propres et
que notre script inclut bien tout ce
qu'il faut pour être exécutée alors pour
vérifier qu'un script de s'exécuter
proprement ce qu'on peut faire sécession
oui starter
démarrèrent au propre
je vais ensuite
demant cliquer sur le petit balai pour
nettoyer tout ce que j'ai en mémoire
et
tu es tout mes lignes de code pour
vérifier que mon script s'exécute
correctement et je peux exécuter toutes
les lignes d'un coup avec le bouton
source
à tour exécuté et donc j'ai bien pensé à
charger les paquets dont j'ai besoin
j'ai bien pensé à importer mes données
et donc du coup tout devrait s'exécuter
et l'ensemble des éléments de l'analyse
si jamais notre script à bien tous les
éléments pour pouvoir se régler quitté
depuis le début et c'est donc ça
l'intérêt en fait d'être sur un script
c'est à dire que on vérifie que tout
peut se faire je peux le transformer
très rapidement en un rapport
automatisés je suis sur mon script est
ici vous voyez le petit bouton ici en
forme de carnet c'est la fonction qu'on
paie louis porte je clique dessus
je vais choix
j'ai un format html je clique sur compil
que ça va faire alors ça c'est un
rapport dans sa version la plus simple
ça va prendre tout code et nous afficher
un document avec code résultats code
résultats code résultats code résultats
l'ag de mendier une sortie acheter
maseda sortie souvent la plus simple et
la plus standard
et normalement
info
faut être patient info
qui ils produisent tous
ça peut prendre parfois quelques
je
je suis en plein stream j'ai un studio
est un peu moins rapide que d'ordinaire
je ne sais pas si vous voyez en dessous
d'eux analyse descriptive point air
1 il est en train de générer un farouche
de fichiers voilà la compilation du
rapport liens de se finaliser
à la fin ça produit un document analyse
descriptive pour html oui ça
un de faire un nouveau document ici je
vais l'ouvrir dans mon navigateur web ce
sera un peu plus lisible
à
et vous avez ici l'ensemble
l'ugta voyez les fonctions mines max on
voit simplement un texte brut par contre
là où j'ai appelé tibial son mari j'ai
les tableaux propres qui sont facilement
copier copiable ecolab lé vous pouvez
ici vous avez aussi directement tous les
graphiques qu'on était inclus à
l'intérieur
et donc vous avez ce que j'ai un rapport
de travail c'est un document vous pouvez
partager à l'extérieur puisqu'il ya tout
le code qui est présent mais vous avez
tous les éléments
alors
juste pour vous montrez vous pouvez
aussi généré votre rapport au format
word par défaut vous pouvez le faire
aussi en pdf la particularité c'est que
pour faire un rapport pdf
il faut que vous ayez latex d'installer
sur votre ordinateur fois un petit peu
compliqué
et donc du coup c'est pas toujours
évident je vous montre ici en version
world ça va prendre à peu près le même
temps et pendant ce temps là je vais les
regarder les dernières questions je vois
qu'il ya un certain nombre de questions
qui sont par rapport à des à des
problématiques d'installation de
certains paquets sous mac
je vais pas pouvoir y répondre là
puisque il faudrait qu'on puisse avoir
un échange plus poussée et c'est pour ça
qu'on a la semaine prochaine une cession
est facultative
le principe d'une cession est
facultative vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions
mais on sera sur zoom et donc du coup
pourrait partager votre écran partagé
la voie est donc du coup on sera en
échange direct ce qui sera plus facile
pour identifier un certain ou de deux
problèmes je vois que certains d'entre
vous disent que certains paquets sont
pas disponibles c'est souvent cas si
vous avez une ancienne version de r il
faut penser à mettre à jour et un studio
d'une part mais il faut aussi penser à
mettre à jour air donc pour vous
rappelle pour ça vous allez télécharger
sur le site air project la dernière
version de r studio
am
il ya une question
dépendance ouvert oui vous pouvez faire
des tests dépendance sauser il faut
savoir qu'on peut faire quasiment tous
les types de tests sous un air ce que je
vous invite là on voit vraiment
l'analyse statistique de base on ira de
dire des choses de plus en plus
compliqué si vous recherchez un type de
tests en particulier ce que je vous
invite à faire c'est aller sur le site
r6 point org donc r6 et un moteur de
recherche d'eads hier la différence
c'est que parfois quand vous cherchez
dans google vous avez des choses qui me
concerne d'autres langages que m et ici
vous pouvez aller chercher de plus
finement le type d'informations que vous
voulez
alors j'ai pour vous montrer r studio
vient de finir de compiler mon rapport
au format word et voyager ici un
document word qui contient les mêmes
éléments
le tableau ici c'est un tableau world
on peut tout à fait du coup ensuite
mettre en forme dans word avec tous les
outils à notre disposition dans word
le graphique est aussi importée donc
vous voyez qu'on peut juste avec cette
petite fonction qu'on parle oui pour
commencer à générer un premier rapport
simple pour faire des choses pires plus
avancé diary remarque down on le verra
quand on aura avancé on est encore
tellement de choses à avoir d'ici là vu
l'heure en tout cas je vous propose de
s'arrêter là pour ce soir
normalement vous avez les éléments pour
faire vos premiers statistiques de base
la semaine prochaine vous les 10 une
cession est facultative voir le lien de
connexion et studio surtout pensez à
vous inscrire à sur wii binaire je vous
rappel sur la page d'accueil du site web
inard on vous indique un comme on vous
inscrire à la mailing list associés il
faut juste envoyé sauce cried webinar à
sympa at least i r&d point fr et donc
vous recevrez le lien sous pour la
semaine prochaine
je pense que la semaine prochaine nous
allons enregistrer sur zoom la vidéo
pour la remettre à disposition pour ceux
qui pourront pas être là retenez ce sera
l'occasion pour vous de poser vos
questions directes donc on aura vraiment
le temps de faire du du du retour et
cette expérience est d'essayer de
répondre à vos problèmes actions au
quotidien
et puis ensuite en début d'année 2021 on
va poursuivre les webinaires en revenant
sur
sur dix plats hier on va commencer à
voir comment avancer de manière plus
fine sur la manipulation de données
aborder la régression logistique aborder
des séances de statistiques plus en plus
poussées mais également des graphiques
avancés voilà retenait encore un laon
j'essaie de faire des choses très courte
en trois séances pour couzier le minimum
de clés pour démarrer pendant les fêtes
de fin d'année sur vos analyses
on est vraiment qu'au tout début encore
merci à vous tous et je vous dis du coup
à la semaine prochaine et je vous
souhaite une très très très bonne fin de
journée
merci à vous